herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
sendung bei philo ist heute habe ich zu
gast dr christoph lena er ist
promovierter philosoph
wissenschaftstheoretiker
wissenschaftsphilosophie mit starken
interesse für physik wo er auch im
abschluss hat wir wollen heute einfach
mal über die frage nach dem verhältnis
von philosophie und physik ein bisschen
diskutieren weil wir die erfahrung
gemacht haben dass viele unsere
teilnehmerinnen zuhörerinnen und zuhörer
großes interesse daran haben zunächst
einmal ganz allgemein wie würden sie das
verhältnis von philosophie und physik
bestimmen weil viele würden ja sagen das
sind zwei ganz verschiedene dinge
philosophie ist nichts was mit
experimenten zu tun hat keine falsifikat
ion von thesen und physik ist sehr stark
angewiesen auf experimente würden sie
sagen dass beide disziplinen miteinander
was zu tun haben oder ihren nicht
historisch auf alle fälle nicht also bis
weit ins 19 jahrhundert rhein war und
den universitäten physik ein teil des
fachgebietes philosophie da hat sich
natürlich inzwischen einiges entwickelt
aber im endeffekt jetzt die moderne
physik aus der idee geboren dass die
viele so viel davon gewinnt wenn man
experimente um 8 nicht also physik war
nichts anderes als experimentelle
philosophie geschichte geht von
experimenten sei es auch wieder
interessant da wollen wir heute
vielleicht nicht so viel darüber
sprechen aber im endeffekt war wie sie
nie etwas anderes als sozusagen
philosophische fragen mit neuen methoden
zu beantworten nicht mit dem
jahrtausendealten idee dass man es durch
begriffliche spekulation lösen kann
sondern dass man eben einfach die welt
anschaut und sich von der natur selber
antworten auf die grundfragen der
philosophie bekommen kann und ich glaube
das ist bis heute aktuell und das ist
insbesondere deswegen immer noch
hochaktuell weil es zu den heute
aktuellen physikalische theorien der
absoluten grundlage unseres weltbildes
nämlich also der relativitätstheorie und
der quantentheorie nicht wirklich gute
philosophische interpretation gibt es
gibt bis zum heutigen tage keinen
wirklichen konsens darüber was bedeutet
es eigentlich
zwar sind philosophisch genau das ist
die nächste frage die ich gerne stellen
möchte sie haben es schon angesprochen
relativitätstheorie und quantentheorie
lassen die sich überhaupt vereinigen in
einer generellen theorie es gibt immer
wieder versuche welche theorie halten
sie für die erfolgreichste das ist also
bis heute wirklich nicht eine
erfolgreiche gelöste fragen der physik
also es gibt bis heute nicht möglich
eine einheitliche theorie die sehr
überzeugend sowohl die grundideen der
quantentheorie also auf die konti dem
relativitätstheorie in einen
begrifflichen rahmen bringen
es gibt ansätze dazu die bekannteste ist
die streng theorie
ich persönlich nicht unbedingt für den
vielversprechenden ansatz halter können
sie die kurz beschreiben für unsere
zuschauer was hast du der stringtheorie
auf die stringtheorie versucht dem
grundannahme der relativitätstheorie das
sozusagen unser universum prinzipiell
raum zeitlich ist also ein raum zeit
kontinuum ist durch einen viel
abstrakteren allgemeineren grundlage zu
ersetzen ist grundlage unserer welt ist
ein viel dimensionalen continum in denen
dieses drinks existierenden erst aus
dieser
wechselwirkung von strings in diesen
viel dimensionalen continum entstehen
überhaupt uns gehören vorstellen also um
die und grundlegenden raum zeitlichen am
verhältnisse ist eine relativ
komplizierte theorie die sehr viele
freiheiten bietet nicht also man kann
die auf sehr verschiedene arten und
weisen konstruieren und man kann dann
versuchen also sozusagen aus den
zahllosen verschiedenen möglichkeiten
einer herauszufiltern die zu unserer
wirklichkeit passt aber da war man
bisher noch nicht erfolgreich nicht es
gibt zwar zahllose möglichkeiten
deswegen kann man bisher auf keinen fall
sagen dass sie widerlegt sei aber
andererseits ist die vielzahl der
möglichkeiten selber für mich sozusagen
ein theoretischer grund verdächtig zu
sein weil die wirklich guten
physikalischen theorien in der
geschichte waren immer die die nicht
sehr viele freie möglichkeiten geboten
haben wo sozusagen mit ein paar
grundgedanken schon alles festgelegt war
nicht und das war eben das
paradebeispiel dafür einsteins
relativitätstheorie sowohl die spezielle
als auch die allgemeine
relativitätstheorie wo sozusagen sobald
die grund aktie festgelegt sind stiegen
tieren nicht und das ist das
fantastische an der theoretischen physik
nicht dass man wirklich sozusagen auf
der grundlage von einem wenigen
grundsätzlichen annahmen ein sehr
reiches theoretisches gebäude aufbauen
kann und da für mich ist ich trinke eben
ganz anders
dann kann man passt ich denke man alles
mögliche zusammenbauen
sie würden sagen die stringtheorie die
ist nicht ein aussichtsreicher kandidat
um diese relativitätstheorie und die
quantentheorie zu vereinigen das ist
nicht der beste keine daten ihrer sicht
entspricht nicht sozusagen mein naturell
nicht ist es alles im endeffekt sind das
wetter vorhersagen wo man sich so auf
sein eigenes bauchgefühl verlässt also
mein bauchgefühl spricht dagegen aber
ich bin auch kein theoretischer physiker
der da an der vorderfront einem
theoretischen entwicklung arbeitet
deswegen halte ich mich da auch etwas
zurück aber wie gesagt mein bauchgefühl
ist er dort leben was ich für mehr
versucht vielversprechend halten ist die
man sozusagen versucht auf der grundlage
der modernen
im feld theorie also sozusagen der
allgemeinen form der quantentheorie die
also dem feld begriffen mit eingreift
eine vereinheitlichung von
quantenfeldtheorie und allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie auf sozusagen
engerer theoretischer basis zu schaffen
wo man nicht zuviel sozusagen an den
grundannahmen ändert sondern sozusagen
etwas näher an den bisherigen theorien
bleibt da hat es in den letzten
jahrzehnten auch interessante
fortschritte gegeben
es ist immer noch nicht gelöst also man
kann nicht sagen dass man da wirklich
schon antworten hätte aber im endeffekt
glaube ich bleibt man da einerseits
näher an den experimenten da weiß man
einfach mehr also da kann man der
astrophysik und mit dem was wir über die
grundlagen der hochenergiephysik gewesen
mehr anfangen und andererseits hat man
einfach weniger theoretische freiheiten
als mann schwebt weniger im leeren und
was was sozusagen überhaupt es an
möglichkeiten geben könnte
all das wird der vorteil gegenüber der
stringtheorie wieder zu vage irgendwie
ist die quantenfeldtheorie wäre in ihren
augen so ein möglicher kandidat für die
quantenfeldtheorie alleine steht ja
schon sozusagen als soll es also sehr
erfolgreich ist theoriegebäude nur ist
sie eben nicht bisher mit der
allgemeinen relativitätstheorie verein
haben sie die quantenfeldtheorie geht
immer von einem vorgegebenen starben am
ebenen raum aus in garmisch starre
nebenraum zeit aus also sozusagen auf
dem stand der speziellen
relativitätstheorie mit der speziellen
relativitätstheorie verträgt sie sich
auch gut aber sozusagen die man dann
dieser raum zeit dynamisch macht was die
grundidee der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie ist nicht das raum
und zeit selber dynamische größen sind
sich verändern können schwingen können
das lässt sich eben bisher nicht
wirklich mit unseren quanten
theoretischen grundannahmen vereinen
dafür gibt es alle möglichen
komplizierten theoretischen begründungen
von denen glaube ich im endeffekt bisher
keine eine endgültige antwort ist also
ich halte immer noch die hoffnung macht
dass man da fortschritte machen kann
jetzt machen sie es schon angesprochen
diese quantentheorie das ist die theorie
die die kleinsten dinge der wirklichkeit
ins auge fasst und da gibt es ja auch
ganz verschiedene interpretationen
dieser quantenzuständen als beispiel
schuldige als katze könnten sie das mal
kurz erklären für unsere zuschauerinnen
schrödingers katze hat jeder schon mal
gehört was hat es damit auf sich mit
diesem gedanken experiment schaidingers
katze ja die grundidee der
quantentheorie ist das sozusagen es die
möglichkeit gibt dass sich verschiedene
zustände überlagern
das ist also ein elektronen in einem
atom nie an einen bestimmten ort ist
sondern wie eine wolke ausgebreitet über
alle möglichen worte die es einnehmen
könnte und diese super positionen sind
so ähnlich wie überlagerungen von wellen
nicht dass heute die ursprüngliche
schuldigen als ursprüngliche idee dass
diese zustände ihnen tatsächlich auch
wellen sind also physikalische melden
irgend eines mediums die sich überlagern
und zu stellen sind absolut essentiell
für die quantenphysik nicht also kein
atom wäre stabil wenn ein elektronen wie
ein kleiner punkt in der gegend herum
sausen würde es kann nur stabil sein
wenn das elektronen zu einer wolfen form
annimmt und andererseits ist es eben so
dass sobald wir messungen machen diese
sich überlagernden zustände immer auf
einen bestimmten spezifischen zustand
den wir messen reduzieren
und genau dieser sprung dieser
quantensprung von und dieser
unbestimmten zustand zu einem bestimmten
gemessenen zustand ist eines der grund
rätsel der quantenphysik das mass
problem
wie kommt es dass also aus dieser wandel
überlagerung plötzlich dann doch ein
eindeutiger zustand wird und um
sozusagen dieses dilemma zu beschreiben
oder sozusagen um das dilemma zu
verschärfen weil man zuerst zunächst
kann man natürlich denken okay das ist
ein problem der mikro physik nicht also
in den atomwahn die elektronen ebenso in
unbestimmten zuständen an sondern warum
und sobald die msn tun sie war seltsam
es aber das passiert halt nur mit
elektronen das ist im mikroskopischen
bereich des feld und sonst nicht weiter
auf
und dagegen hat schrödinger dieses
gedankenexperiment erfunden vom von
seiner katze in mit dem land mit ganz
einfachen mitteln beschreibt dass jeder
solcher mikroskopische
überlagerungszustand auch einen
makroskopischen überlagerungszustand
nach sich folgern sie ja nicht also die
versuchsaufbau ist einfach der sie
sperren eine katze mit einer
teufelsmaske in einen kasten und die
trails maschine besteht einfach daraus
dass ein zerfallen ist ein einzelnes
zerfallen das atom eine freisetzt und
die kein atom zerfällt wie man zu einem
bestimmten zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
sondern es gibt ja genau diese
überlagerung von möglichen zerfall
also ist atomen braucht in seiner
halbwertszeit hat es kann das zu jedem
dieser zeit punkte zerfallen und die
quantenmechanik sagt uns nie das ist
also irgendwann einen bestimmten
zeitpunkt gibt wann dieses atome
zerfallen ist sondern all diese
verschiedenen zerr fälle existieren
gleichzeitig wo sind hin und daraus
folgt also wiederum nach der
quantenmechanik das eben der moment wenn
die katze getötet wird genauso völlig
unbestimmt ist und sozusagen zu jedem
zeitpunkt in diesem kasten eine
überlagerung stattfindet von einer noch
lebenden katze weil das atom noch nicht
verfallen ist und einer toten katze weil
das atome zerfallen ist es gift
freigesetzt hat und sozusagen erst in
dem moment wo wir nachschauen würde
würde sich das ihm zu sagen bestimmten
zustand reduzieren und das fand
schrödinger eine absolut absurde
vorstellung nicht ist das ist die
kernidee seines gedankenexperiment ist
so kam die welt nicht sein dass er
konkurrenten tui tief man denkt also die
katze ist die ganze zeit dieselbe und
nicht erst bestimmt wenn ich das
experiment durchführen nachschauen wie
es jetzt aussieht was folgt denn da
jetzt philosophisch daraus ich habe
schon mal von dieser theorie der
möglichen der vielen welten
hört das wäre eine mögliche
interpretation dieses experiments können
sie das ein bisschen beschreiben diese
viele welten theorie interpretation der
quantenmechanik vielleicht noch vor ein
kurzer schritt zurück man kann natürlich
jetzt einfach sagen irgendwas stimmt an
der quantenmechanik nicht also dass das
sozusagen diese vorstellung dass diese
super position also auf ewig weiter
existieren und sich nie von ihm zu einem
bestimmten zustand reduzieren die kann
auch vielleicht einfach theoretisch
falsch sein
und das ist also die idee von
verschiedenen interpretationen der
quantenmechanik nicht einerseits gibt es
diese so genannten hidden very worries
theorien der verborgenen parameter die
zuerst von david ohm vorgeschlagen
wurden das ist tatsächlich neben den
quantenmechanischen stellen auch
wirklich zustände gibt die eine
bestimmte definierte physikalische
qualität haben oder es gibt die
möglichkeit also spontan irgendwie diese
reaktion
diese diese reduktion von zuständen gibt
da ist also irgendwann spontan es
passiert dass das dass diese
unbestimmten zustände definiert werden
oder die andere alternative ist man
glaubt eben dem theoretische konstrukt
der korken mechanik und sagt diese
unbestimmten zustände existieren
tatsächlich immer weiter es ist eben
tatsächlich so dass die katze sowohl tot
und lebendig ist und dass die
beobachtungen also unsere beobachtung
auch nichts ändert an dieser tatsache
sondern wir selber als beobachter
ebenfalls in vielen möglichen zustände
existieren darf nur eben selber nicht
warum wir existieren in diesem zuge
stellen aber wir sind nicht in der lage
sozusagen über unseren eigenen
wahrnehmung john tripp aus zuschauen
wir sehen immer nur einen aspekt dieser
vielen vielen möglichkeiten in die
quantenmechanik bietet die alle
gleichzeitig nebeneinander existieren
und das ist die macworld interpretation
das ist sozusagen die quantenmechanik
und sagt das ist nicht nur eine
wirklichkeit gibt sondern es gibt ein
unendliches kontinuum von möglichkeiten
und unsere wirklichkeit nur ein
subjektiver aspekt ist eben nur die
wahrnehmung
dies ist ein dieser einen möglichkeit
aus den vielen die objektiv existieren
das führt mich zur nächsten frage
nämlich der frage nach der freiheit naja
man sagt ja häufig quantenzustände
ziemlich genau determiniert sie haben
nur wahrscheinlichkeit verteilungen
spricht jetzt die quantentheorie er für
die freiheit des menschlichen willens
oder er dagegen weil man ja auch sagen
könnte daher gut wenn das alles
irgendwie ein bisschen willkürlich
zufällig ist das ist ja auch nicht
gerade das was sie in der freiheit
verstehen freiheit er hat immer so eine
gewisse art von bestimmtheit wenn auch
nicht von brede terminiert haid und
notwendigkeit was würden sie dann zu
sagen das ist also uralte dilemma nicht
unsere theorien der freiheit einerseits
determinismus nicht also wenn alles von
anfang der welt determinierte wäre
verträgt sich nicht gut mit unserer
vorstellung von freiheit anderer ist als
blinder zufall ist auch nicht unsere
vorstellung von freiheit nicht also wenn
also eine entscheidung die ich treffen
nur davon abhängen wie jetzt zufällig
ein atom irgendwo in meinem hirn
gesprungen ist dann ist es auch nicht
das was wir uns unter freiheit
vorstellen was man darauf antworten
dies wiederum sozusagen eine frage die
allgemeiner ist jetzt als die als
sozusagen die die die quantenmechanik
selber nicht also man hat jetzt eine
angleichung mit mehreren unbekannten
eine gleichung mit mehreren unbekannten
nicht also einerseits haben wir schon
klassisch nicht wirklich eine sehr gute
theorie auf die konsistenz zwischen
unseren begriffen von freiheit und und
den grundlagen der physik um außerdem
wissen wir nicht wirklich was die physik
und sagt über diese grundlagen nicht
also man kann die quantenmechanik geben
einerseits völlig deterministisch
interpretieren diese einstein und bumm
gemacht haben dass es wirklich eine
deterministische theorie ist oder man
kann sagen es ist eine radikal in
deterministische theorie in der eben
tatsächlich zu fälle vorkommen weiß ich
eben ganz interessant finde an dieser
many ways interpretation ist also ich
glaube dass sie einen ausweg aus diesem
dilemma bietet das ist sozusagen uns
eine möglichkeit bietet eine theorie von
handlungen zu machen
über dieses alte klassische dilemma
hinausgeht die uns erlaubt sozusagen
eine vorstellung von freiheit zu
entwickeln die nicht deterministisch ist
weil diese konnten mechanische welt eben
nur dieter nuhr deterministisch ist in
einem in einer art und weise gar nicht
verstehen können nicht weil sie also nur
den gesamtheit aller möglichkeiten ist
eine deterministische welt also
deterministisch ist diese welt nicht in
der die wir wahrnehmen diese einzelne
wirklichkeit die wir haben ihnen aber
andererseits ist sie auch nicht in
deterministisch in dem simplen sinne
dass zufallsereignisse stattfinden weil
was wir sehen ist ja immer nur ein
bestimmter aspekt dieser dieser
ansammlung wirklichkeit deswegen und auf
die details nicht jetzt werde ich auf
zeit fragen lieber nicht eingehen
die habe ich dass es wirklich so zu
sagen wenn man es akzeptiert dass die
metaphysik radikal anders ist also
bisher vorgestellt haben da auch
interessante neue antwort und geben
könnte zu eben solchen grundbegriffen
wie der menschlichen freiheit ja das ist
also wirklich sehr zentral für die
philosophie einen kleinen einwand hätte
ich noch gegen diese mini worlds
interpretation es gibt ja dieses
sogenannte organische rasiermesser des
organs racer was er gesagt wir sollen
die dinge die wir annehmen die entitäten
nicht unnötigerweise vervielfältigt
multiplizieren das wäre doch bei seiner
my world theorie eigentlich der fall
ohne dass wir von vielen welten ausgehen
so fahren wir nicht besser wenn wir nur
von einer welt ausgehen was ist der
unterirdische vorteil sie sich daran
erinnern was organ damals mit entitäten
meinte er meinte nicht einzelne
gegenstände eher meiden nicht objekte in
der welt von denen gibt es sehr viele
unendlich es geht darum und kategorien
um kategorien unserer gegend camorra
argumentierte waren die universal ian
der arrest at lia die begriffe die nicht
unnötig multipliziert werden sollen und
in begrifflichen entitäten ist die
mainboards interpretation tatsächlich
die absolut sparsamste von allen
interpretationen der quantenmechanik
wenn es gibt eben nur die reine
quantenmechanik und nicht irgendwelche
zusätzlichen prozesse die jetzt
irgendwie unsere wirklichkeiten daher
stellen nicht also begrifflich ist im
medical center plantation das sehr
sparsam und wie groß die welt ist nicht
also wie viele objekte in ihr
tatsächlich sind darüber kann die
philosophie keine aussagen machen nicht
also das müssen wir tatsächlich imperium
hat lassen glaube ich ja das ist eine
sehr sehr einleuchtende erklärung finde
ich wir haben wir glaube ich noch zeit
für eine frage dass wir aufhören ja wir
hatten durch ja dann vielen dank für das
sehr hellen de-interview zum verhältnis
von philosophie und physik wir
verabschieden uns bei unseren zuschauern
bis zur nächsten sitzung